hello and welcome to our webinar my name
is Stuart Creek I'm with simply learn
we're waiting for a professor
Ramesh to join us all right
and we'll be talking about
becoming a business analyst with program
from IIT rookie let's get started
so
our agenda today is to talk a little bit
about you because we will have some
polls that we'll be asking you members
of the audience
um we'll talk about business analysis
careers and what this program offers
how it gets your job ready and the steps
to enroll if you are interested
and
while we're
expecting Professor Ramesh to join us I
will get started
just to be sure
that we get underway
sure that not possibly here in another
capacity no okay
so we expect him to join us he may have
had a conflict but if he does he is the
associate professor of the Department of
management studies at IIT work and so he
deals with
uh Supply Chain management
Six Sigma and data analytics which of
course directly relates to the business
analytics program
so about careers in business Analytics
business analysis is really more than
essential than ever especially since the
onset of the pandemic
um
we we have seen an explosion of data
when we moved to work from home and
non-contact transactions
um there is an explosion of data because
everything that we were doing in person
now had to be done uh over the Internet
or over mobile devices and each of those
interactions generates data then we have
Internet of things which is generating
even more data about the world around us
that means that business managers and
leaders have to deal with this flood of
data and find out how to extract
insights and guidance from it
data by itself is information without
meaning and
it's the job of the business analyst to
extract meaning from that information so
um
the business analyst has a vital role in
helping management understand
what all of this means what the
environment around them is based on the
data what the environment and future
ahead holds based on the data and its
predictive values and what that means in
terms of prescriptions for what the
business should do to prepare for its
future so
um business analyst
provides that translation of the data
into business insights for management
and so that job has become
again more essential than ever
it encompasses a number of different
potential roles
a business analysts project managers
data analysts
um
these are the average salaries but the
ranges of these salaries go far higher
um and you can find that out from
um
sources like Glassdoor and indeed
and you need to have up-to-date skills
for business analytics career
obviously business analytics as a
foundation
understanding the statistic principles
behind it descriptive statistics that
talk about
what the data tells you about how the
world exists today
prescriptive statistics that tell you
about what you can do to reach your
goals in the future and predictive
statistics that provide models that
predict what will happen in the future
you have data analytics
you have data visualization which is a
key part of the business analysts career
and
the data visualization is part of the
process of Storytelling
to to take your insights and turn them
into a form that is easily accessible
and understandable by management
you need to understand the principles of
modeling including linear regression
logistic regression you need to
understand
how to test hypotheses and how to
explore the data
um
you need to be able to build dashboards
based on storyboards and you need
to understand
the ways to Aggregate and automate the
process so
all of these skills are part of the
repertoire that you need as a business
analyst I'm going to ask a question in
the audience at this point
and the question is what has stopped you
up until now from
starting a program of this type and
becoming a business analysis expert
is it because you haven't found a
program with a comprehensive curriculum
is it because
you don't think you'd get the practical
exposure that you need
is it because you don't find it easy to
learn from pre-recorded materials
or is it because you don't have enough
time in your schedule for this leave
that open for a couple more moments so
of our attendees we have
the about half who have said that they
don't feel they'd get the Practical
exposure that they would need
from
uh the
program
though we'll also see that a number of
you think that
your work schedule doesn't allow time
for you to do this
can't find a program with Comprehensive
curriculum so let me share that with you
for a moment and then we'll move on so
let's talk about the program from IIT
rookie
um business analytics for decision
strategic decision making and this is a
program that uh is delivered in
collaboration with IBM simply learning
is the delivery partner that provides a
platform for sharing this program with
you it is delivered entirely online on a
platform available 24x7
so that you can do most of your work on
your own schedule whenever you have the
time rather than
fixed times there will be classes that
are held live virtual classes that give
you the opportunity to interact with
your instructor and your peers in the
program
and these live classes are on a schedule
um but other than that all the other
work that you do for the case studies
and Hands-On projects you do uh on the
online platform
and
on your own schedule as we'll talk in a
moment the curriculum is very
comprehensive covers a wide spectrum of
the skills we talked about
for business Analytics and
um
it's
completely online so it is available to
you 24 7.
the QR code takes you to our program
page if you're interested
and we'll share that link also later
you receive certificates from IIT rookie
and from IBM as you complete the program
in the courses within it
um
this certifies that you have completed
the core courses mastered the skills in
the program uh it also certifies that
you mastered the particular sub skills
from the different IBM courses and
electives
you also have access to IBM hackathons
ask me anything sessions master classes
master classes from IIT rookie and job
assist career assistance program from
Simply learned talk about that in a few
minutes
and about IIT rookie it is the nation's
seventh IIT Indian Institute of
Technology
um it has a 175 year history
with over 8 000 students in the student
body and over 500 faculty
um and the department of management
studies which offers this program is
ranked number one in nirt ranking
so this is a
fantastic institution it's prestigious
and it will be a
great asset on your resume but we also
have the IBM Advantage so one of the
cool things about the program is that uh
you have IBM working professionals who
are teaching some of the courses
um
specific skills in our programming in
Python
and you also have access to the master
classes and ask me anything sessions and
hackathons
um throughout the program so this is a a
great opportunity to get practical
exposure to practitioners in the
industry
really adds value to this program
job assists service from Simply learn
one of the things that we provide as
additional value beyond the certificate
so once you've earned your certificate
you have six additional months of job
assistance services
provide this for Learners in India
um
with IIT job or IIM jobs I'm sorry and
uh you receive several different things
one is access to expert webinars and
career events that simply learn puts on
these are free
um you have the option to do the
different real world projects in your
Capstone which we'll talk about a little
bit more but that becomes part of your
portfolio that you can demonstrate
to um
people when you go out interviewing and
finally uh the specific job assist
services from IIM jobs includes access
to their job portal with some exclusive
job listings
valuable piece of the puzzle in helping
you in your
job
search but
I think more of a valuable are the other
two parts
the resume review and rewrite service
is important because today resumes have
to serve two purposes one they have to
get past an AI filter in automated
tracking systems that companies use
and so these
Services allow you to get your resume
into a form that the AI filter can
easily recognize and evaluate against
job description
but it also gives you a chance to um
format your resume in the form that is
still attractive to human beings when it
gets to their desktop or their screen
because it still has to be once it gets
through the AI filter it has to be
attractive to the hiring manager so
this Suite of services it's extremely
valuable as is the one-on-one interview
service
which gives you the chance to practice
two kinds of interviews one is the
technical interview for your new
business analytics skills
um the second is the
types of management fit teamwork and
team building interviews that show that
you're a valuable
addition to the
the company so you need to be able to
present your best foot forward in both
of those situations
the one-on-one interview service allows
you to practice that and own the skills
for both of those
as I mentioned there are expert webinars
and career sessions these are free these
are conducted by simply learn on an
ongoing basis so those are available to
you
the rest of your career and
then we have the industry aligned
projects so
the projects will become part of your
portfolio you pick one or more of the
the different Capstone options
create a complete solution built up from
scratch and that demonstrates that you
have the skills to do the work
and it shows as practical experience of
this is the kind of work you do and how
you do it so
these are all valuable parts of this
program
and help you in your job search again
not a job guarantee but a job search
assistance program for eligibility and
prerequisites
you have to
um
you have to have a drive to apply
business analytics Concepts the real
world problems well we're asking for
people to have
work experience at least six years of it
but you do not have to have coding
experience or technology knowledge
because you'll gain that during the
program so
with that
I'm going to ask a question
just to get a feel for who's in the
audience how many years of experience do
you currently have
as you're going through please put
questions into the Q a we'll handle them
from there
uh much easier I'm seeing a lot of
traffic in the chat so it's much easier
to find the questions in the Q a so if
you would put your questions there and
uh
further in the chat already please
transfer below transfer them over
and we're watching the numbers change
and they're slowing down so I'm going to
end the poll
now
share the results
and we have a little over a third of the
audience are people who are currently
studying
um and we have about a third of the
audience or people with more than five
years of experience so
um
the people with more than five years of
experience certainly meet the
qualification the people with
zero to five years of experience
talk to our learning Consultants at ask
us at simplylearn.net in order to
evaluate your criteria
um people are currently studying
probably want to wait until they
complete their studies in order to take
this program but again contact our
learning consultants and ask that
question uh generally we tell people
that uh if you're currently studying but
you plan to graduate by the time these
the program is over
and you can enroll so let's talk about
how this program repairs you
will describe the learning environment
to you the learning environment is the
online environment allows you to manage
your curriculum
it shows you all the courses that
comprise the program and it unlock
unlocks each one's access as you
complete the one before so you start off
with the orientation session which gives
you access to your first course
finishing the first course
allows you to get to the second one and
so forth that's to build up your skills
in a particular
deafwise fashion you have the online
virtual classroom which allows you to
interact directly with the instructors
follow on with their
materials and do the exercises with them
then you have the ability to do labs and
tests
on the platform itself
a sandboxed environment with a virtual
machine so you don't have to have
separate laptop or desktop computer
environment of your own you can do it
through the virtual machine that's
provided to you the Capstone project
we'll talk about again in a few minutes
that gives you
the final proof that you've completed
the program and mastered the skills and
along the way you get to manage your
progress see how you're doing you get
reminders from the system
prompt you to catch up if you've fallen
behind in the area and when you complete
each course it unlocks a certificate for
that course and again it gives you
access to the next course in the series
until you finally complete the Capstone
and unlock the final certificate from
IIT working so you have support tools
along the way you can contact
our technical support 24 7 if you have
questions about the platform you can
contact our subject matter experts 24 7
you have questions or doubts about the
material and you have the ability to
access your library of videos
of recordings of past classes
access to any of the
other materials that your instructors
have shared with you all of that
available plus you have an online
community of your fellow Learners so
that you can turn to them for support
and help
as you complete the program the
program's curriculum builds up as I
mentioned in the stepwise fashion
core
program
starts with the orientation session that
gets you a review of what the program
will include and how to use the learning
management system
then it moves into the foundations of
data analytics and principles behind
how to extract meaning from data
moves into statistical analysis for
vision business decision making and
being able to understand which
statistical distributions apply to the
types of data that you're looking at for
any given problem how to build models
along those lines
um you then move into exploratory data
analysis and visualization so this is
where you learn skills in our
programming which is a standard tool for
data analysis
then you start looking at Predictive
Analytics for big business which allow
you to create models that predict what
will happen in the future based on
patterns of data in the past
you then go into prescriptive analytics
for business which allow you to make
judgments and recommendations about what
changes and policies you may need to
make in order to achieve the goals that
you're looking at
um finally data science and machine
learning for decision making going a
little bit deeper into the technology
and especially into the more advanced
tools of machine learning that allow
your models to improve themselves as you
get more data about the real world
and then the Capstone project which ties
all of these skills together where you
pick a problem to solve and generate the
solution on your own more about that in
a moment
along the way you have electives you can
take the academic master class from IIT
rookie you can take industry master
classes from the IBM
instructors you have your data analysis
with python elective
taught by IBM you can also take
data visualization with python and
mathematical optimization for business
problems both by IBM so all of these are
included in the program
no additional cost you decide whether
you have the time and the inclination to
take those electives
so the tools in the framework pardon me
tools and Frameworks are going to learn
include
um basic tools of Excel and power bi but
then the programming uh
languages of python and R
using MySQL for management of data and
Tableau for visualization
just as I mentioned an important aspect
of business Analytics
these are all tools that you will learn
and that you will use and we'll be able
to say on your resume
not only listing these skills but also
having backup in your portfolio to
demonstrate that you can use these
effectively and the Capstone project as
I mentioned the Capstone project allows
you to showcase the future employers
uh
a practical problem that you've done
you pick from several different domains
the project or problem description that
most interests you and you work with
your instructor for three to four weeks
meeting with them weekly to make sure
that you stay on track that you don't uh
all into any blockers and that you can
then complete the per the Capstone
project in a timely fashion
and that gets evaluated basically as the
final exam for the program it shows that
you have
been able to solve this problem on your
own
with the skills that you've learned
testing it with real world real world
data sets that have been brought in for
the purpose
so again it's a three to four week
process
under the tutelage of your instructor
and comes up with a final project that
becomes part of your permanent portfolio
that you can demonstrate to employers
both your current employer or future
employers
but let's talk about the uh
leaders of the program on the IIT rookie
side Professor ramash or we mentioned
also Professor Tarn Sharma
who is the assistant professor of
operations in the department of
management studies and Professor I mean
page who is the assistant professor in
the department of management studies and
these people uh do research and uh
backgrounds in
data analytics and business analytics so
these are people who are experts and
have designed those curriculum
for this program
learner outcomes let's talk about a
particular learner outcome hopefully
this will work
this is sudiptosh you can read along
with you know everybody
my ticket long experience in the
business development sector has made me
realize you must know how to analyze
data and statistics to grow in your
career I plan to use the business
analytics strategic decision making
course which I did from IIT roorkee and
simply learned to pursue the Senior
Management roles
I have 12 years plus of experience in
business development currently I'm
planning to launch my own startup with
my friends recently I realized the
importance of data analytics for making
business decisions when I started my
career that technology was not that vast
and data is not readily available but
now it is I have also realized that
companies are looking for people with
the knowledge of machine learning so I
decided to choose a professional
certificate
before choosing simply learn I look for
other platform too but the course simple
line provides covers everything the
association with IIT rookie makes the
certification internationally recognized
in fact my channel is simply learn begin
when I took a course from skill up and I
was really impressed it made me
confident about choosing this course my
experience with simply learn has been
amazing the course is comprehensive and
covers subject of my interest it has R
it has python it has SQL but also
something I have always wanted to learn
now I think I'm ready to make a new
beginning
I am going to change my domain from
Business Development to Big Data
learning and Analysis I am looking
forward handling project and handling
the profit and loss of my organization I
believe the learning from the course
will be very beneficial there I wanted
to be in a Senior Management Group and I
believe this course will help me to get
there I want to thank my wife who has
been very supportive throughout my
journey I am happy that we have such an
amazing platform which actually quench
my thirst of learning we should never
stop learning
all right thank you so much for that and
I hope that
gives you a good feeling for
what the program can do for you
personally
I'm going to add another
whole question here
and basically just are you interested
based on what you've learned so far
about the program
would you like to enroll let's let this
run for about 20-30 seconds
so over 80 percent of you uh said that
you're interested in joining the program
let's share with you how that process
works the enrollment steps are
straightforward first you submit your
application at ask us at simplylearn.net
and I am going to share that information
in the chat right now once you submit
the application we will evaluate the
application based on the criteria and
eligibility prerequisites for the
program now you have that link in the
email address
um and once we reviewed the application
you'll get an admission offer uh if you
qualify
purpose of the application review of
course is to uh get confidence that
you'll be able to complete the program
successfully
um because it is a commitment of time
and effort and financial commitment as
well so we don't want it to um
let you into the program
to set you up for failure we want to
admit you to the program with the
greatest possible chance of success so
the next
cohort of this program begins on 27th
January with the orientation
classes start the next day
on 28th January cost of the program is
one lock 49 000.
and this can be financed over time zero
cost financing
forty nine thousand forty six a month
and you ask if you have an employer who
has a tuition reimbursement policy you
should ask about that
um because they may be able to
subsidize the program for you some
employers do have that policy where they
will either pay for the course or
reimburse you once you complete it so
for more information please contact us
at ask us at simplylearn.net which I put
into the chat and our learning
Consultants will be able to answer
and questions you might have at this
point all right I want to ask
do the questions and answers I'm going
to stop sharing the screen because you
don't need to stare at the slide and
so this point I want to um apologize
that Professor Ramesh was not able to
join us today
but I will answer the questions to my
ability and we'll be able to pass some
of those on to him
uh if there are additional questions so
again anything that's in the Q a I will
be able to
um
care
um the difference between Siddharth asks
the difference between business
analytics and data analytics
and that's a great question data
analytics is
the
umbrella over
business Analytics
it is the set of skills and techniques
and tools that allow you to extract
information
from data
business analytics applies data
analytics to the business environment so
it looks at practical applications of
data analytics
to help management make decisions about
where they are and what they need to do
to achieve goals so
um
business Analytics
does have a bigger component of
presentation and storytelling because
you need to be able to present your
findings
to management in a way that's accessible
to them so you may have looked at a
fundamentals of the statistics behind a
problem
you don't want to have to go through
that entire process to translate that
for management you want to be able to
say this is what we learned and
if you're curious how we learned it this
is kind of the basics of how we came up
to that
understanding so
that's the basic difference between
business analytics and data analytics
um
Prasad asks a great question I have
overall five years of experience in a
different domain is it worth doing this
and is that experience considered yes
your experience in other domains is
considered for the prerequisite um
whether this is uh valuable to you to do
is based on whether you want to be in uh
the business analytics field if you have
a
desire or passion for it
um and want to be able to solve those
kinds of problems and present that
information to management have that kind
of interaction
with senior managers
um
this is a great program for you if you
come out of a different domain generally
what that means is you have domain
experience
and so when you gain the skills for
business Analytics
you can apply them specifically to the
domain you're familiar with and it makes
you more powerful uh as a practitioner
in that domain itself
um
so Sohail says I am 40 years old I hope
I'm not telling your secret style but
um having six years work experience and
if I do this will it be worth doing
um this is extremely valuable set of
skills
um it gives you access to a new field or
or aspect of your career
it lets you I mentioned for Assad that
you will have new tools to apply in the
domain that you're familiar with it'll
also give you the ability to Pivot into
a new type of work so
um again if if business analytics is
something that you are interested in
feel uh passionate about absolutely this
is a good program for you and we have an
anonymous question from someone with
only two years of experience and no
experience in coding or Analytics you do
not need to have a background in coding
or analytics to succeed in this program
the program will give you that
background so
you'll be taking classes and learning
how to code in Python in R we'll be
learning the techniques of data
analytics and how to use them in the
business analytics context
if you have two years and four months of
work experience contact our
learning Consultants that ask us at
simplylearn.net ask about
your eligibility again the six year work
experience as a recommendation it is not
a hard and fast rule so you'll want to
ask
about your eligibility
sounds like if you're if you have the
desire and the interest you can succeed
talk our friend to ask about the
difference between business analytics
and data science again we've talked
about that with the provision that data
science
um is more it can include more
theoretical
applications rather than the practical
application of analytics to
data problems or business problems
data science can look into a
more of exploring different potential
models different techniques
so that
the data scientists can generate the
Frameworks models and the tools that
then the data analyst business analyst
apply so uh
and someone asks if there's a
certificate after the session this is
not the type of session that simply
learned gives certificates for uh I
showed you act of the access to the
other types of career and Technology
sessions and things like mini classes
and that type of thing so for those we
do provide proof of attendance
certificates
um this is a program preview so
basically it's not an instructional
informational or instructional type of
situations more information also
um I apologize for that but what are the
requisites become organized as a better
business analyst and I think we've we've
covered we've covered the question in
terms of the prerequisites that you need
to join the program
what we feel is that the curriculum the
way it's structured
um meets all of the
prerequisites that you need to be
qualified as a business analyst so the
end of the process you receive a
certificate from IIT rookie along with
the sub certificates from IBM that
certify that you have those skills and
do this work and on that career so
hope that answers your question and we
had a question about whether Professor
ramish will join the session again I
apologize not sure why he was not able
to join today he was set to join but uh
not seeing the message about what
interfered so my apologies for that but
I will
be sending out a follow-up email to this
session and I'll include his LinkedIn
information so you can
contact him
uh assistant again what should we focus
more on that will depend on your
particular interests and what your job
description will call for when you get
into this field but yes you can look at
you we want to make sure that you're
well-rounded and can take on uh
challenges from various different
aspects so understanding descriptive
predictive and prescriptive
techniques of of analysis are all part
of the course so that you can take on
the challenges of uh either a problem
like how do we know what our seasonal
demand will be for this product so that
we can plan our our
production rates
that's a predictive problem where you
look at the past patterns of data and
seasonality and then you can make
predictions about what expected sales
will be and therefore tell the factories
how many of the product you need on what
time schedule
you can look at predictive or a
prescriptive to say you know of these
several different potential product
areas that we could move into
which has the best chance of success
therefore make a recommendation to your
management about where to make that
investment so those are the kinds of
problems that you'll
you'll be qualified to address
from this
pradeep says I'm not from a technical
background will I be able to understand
the course content
the answer to that is generally speaking
yes
if you are able to grasp the concepts of
uh programming of data analysis
you don't have to have those in your
background you just need to have the
Curiosity and the aptitude for them
that'll be part of the evaluation of
your application so you can contact us
at ask us at simplywin.net
get more information about how to get
that evaluated
is this possible after a four-year Gap
yes it is if your skills are
uh if your abilities are still sharp
and you're not too rusty but the purpose
of the program is to bring you up to
speed
so if you have a gap
that should not be a blocker for you
what are job titles related to business
analytics so yes business analysts
junior senior moving up the scale
project manager business analytics could
be applied in product management
it can be applied in operations have
business titles that are in those types
of departments or
functional areas
and so there's a variety there working
as a
senior project manager we have an
anonymous question working as a senior
project manager how the program will
help me if I have over 18 years of
experience and have worked on various
projects as a business analyst if you're
qualified as a business analyst
currently um
and
this you'll want to evaluate carefully
if this will add the skills capabilities
to your your personal portfolio that
will make you better at it
um if you are already working in the
field and qualified you may want to look
at other programs that go deeper into
particular
subjects like machine learning and that
type of thing so
um you may want to ask our learning
Consultants about whether this is a good
fit for you because certainly if you're
already at that point you may not want
to take a
Preparatory program of this time so what
is it about
barava has asked what is this about and
so I hope that I was able to cover
what the principles of business analysis
are and why it's a valuable field for
you
um we will then
so I have seven years of experience in
sales and marketing says arvind
uh how will of course will help me and
what kind of salary hike could you get
from your current level so the um
the value for someone in sales and
marketing or business analytics you
already rely on business analysts to
help you the things like as I mentioned
predictions of sales demand
um evaluating the potential of new
products that type of thing so having
those skills on your own
will allow you to be less dependent on
other people and more able to provide
that information yourself and be
a source of that information for your
organization
um
that adds value to you in your current
domain and
we can't necessarily guarantee salary
hikes although the typical salary hike
we've seen people get from this program
in other situations
has been
pretty substantial 50 or more
but this is again depends on your
current based salary and and what
potential you have for that so after
completion of business analysis course
and having work experience of seven
years and you directly apply for
business analyst role
so the whole intent behind this program
is that once you have completed it
you will be qualified to apply for
business analyst roles
and we will provide you with job
assistance to help you find those
um so
the answer to that is yes
darcar who says I want to get into
management consultancy from a customer
service representative role will this be
beneficial to get into a managerial role
or will allow you to jump into the
consultant role
um so
the
business analytics skill set is valuable
to Consultants
in terms of
allowing them to to tell their customers
or their their
clients
what are the
possible Futures that they can plan for
how can they shape their future
um
so it's extremely important aspect of
management consultancy
um
whether it's the best path for you into
management consultancy is a different
question
um
you may want to take more of a general
Management program in order to
understand a broader spectrum of
management principles
but again having business Analytics
capabilities is extremely valuable
people who are in management Consultants
because consultancy because
being able to make those types of
analyzes and recommendations Based on
data is vitally important
and um
I would go to our
website for this next questions
subembala has asked what would be
expected annual compensation for
business Analytics
there are two ways to look that up one
is to go to our program page we have
some information there but the other is
to go to
uh
job search site like Glassdoor indeed or
that type of thing
and see what the salary ranges are for
business analysts and related
job titles and you can get a feel for
you know what types of salary potential
are out there
how does this happen help a management
information systems analyst
and um
so one of the interesting things to
chaitanya is that um
as an Mis analyst you may be looking at
things like
capacity planning
now capacity planning will depend on
the predicted
volume of transactions predicted demand
for services
that your systems have to support
and so the um
business analytics is extremely helpful
in that area it's also helpful in
analyzing
performance of systems
and modeling how they work and
how they will respond to for example
seasonal spikes in demand and that type
of thing so
it can be a very valuable tool for uh
management information systems analysts
hey
uh
someone on a Samsung has asked how will
this certificate help
we grow
come from a Commerce background
um
retail bankings and operations
the interesting aspect of that is that
business Analytics
especially things that involve machine
learning
transformed
retail banking banking operations
with the emergence of things like
fintech where
now systems are able to make credit
decisions that used to take a human
evaluators
days of the systems can make those
decisions within a minute
and
the people who build the models for that
come from a business analytics
background can come from
an artificial intelligence background
that type of thing
um
but it kind of illustrates how
um field
Banking and commerce has changed and how
much more data dependent it is
so
being able to have these skills
um
a valuable addition for somebody in that
field
the question about whether this is
recorded class or live class
so the course program
includes live classes taught online by
live instructors you get to interact
with them ask questions follow along the
exercises they're doing
the classes are recorded in case you
miss them but the requirement is to
attend a certain number of the classes
live you can't go into the program with
the intention that you'll
catch up the courses from recordings all
the time do you have to interact there's
live class participation as part of your
qualification
there's also other materials that are
pre-recorded materials for viewing or
reading in between the live classes as
preparation so
all of that material live classes
recorded materials
data files all of that is available to
you through the same learning management
system all in one place
how to switch with four years of BPO
operation experience
so
again similar to the Mis
practitioner
if you're in business process operations
then
business analytics as part of your
planning and load balancing and that
type of thing all very important
so
it may be something you want to add
to your BPO domain experience it may be
something that will enable you to Pivot
into
analytics for other domains
um
duration of the course number of hours
per week
next course starting I think we've
covered the
all that you'll be able to see on the um
recording that we'll share with you
you'll be able to review that
information but you'll also be able to
get that from our
program page on our website
um
the
average number of hours committed per
week is somewhere between 10 and 15. but
that includes the live courses as well
as the in between work and then the
duration is six months
next course starts on the 27th of
January
if a person is already Python and R
certified will that help certainly it
helps because you're you'll have a head
start on some of the the
course materials uh
that you'll need
um and you'll get a valuable
additional refresher Within
program on the
R and python module so
it's all very valuable
um
and can we describe the course contents
there is a syllabus available from our
web page on the website so please go
there download the syllabus take a look
at that
and with that I think we've reached the
end of the
questions listed or at the end of time
for our program I'm going to ask two
last
polls for you the first one is if you
have said you're interested
how soon would you like to start is this
something you want to do on the
cohort that's coming up on the 27th of
January
or is it something you want to do on the
next chord after that or is it something
that you're looking for down the road
we'll let this run for about 30 seconds
okay and the numbers have stopped
changing so I'm going to end the poll
and share that with you
44 who said they'd like to start
immediately and then another
25 who'd like to start within three
months that would be the cohort
immediately after
so again this is something
this is something worth doing that's
going to change your career and your
life for the better we always recommend
that you do it sooner than later but um
it's encouraging to see the
almost 70 percent of the audience is
interested in getting started pretty
quickly
um we'll do one last pull and this is
for anybody who's interested in
enrolling
do you need assistance from us
getting that process started
let's leave this open for about 15
seconds
please get your answers in and I will
close the poll
five four
three two
one
and it's about 50 50 in terms of
people who need some assistance from us
through ask us at simplywin.net and
people feel confident they're ready to
get started so
with that
share the result here
stop sharing
and we will
conclude the webinar thank you to
everyone who's here we have again the QR
code available to go to our website and
I will put into the chat again
information about
how to get to the website and how to
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
that's in the chat right now I want to
thank everyone who joined us today again
my apologies uh that professor
romesh was unable to join us today
I will um
include his LinkedIn
contact in the follow-up email
and
I hope everyone has a great day we would
like to welcome you into the IIT working
learning community
so we hope we can help you with that a
great evening great day Wherever You Are